and his conscience was bothered and he
repented that's why Christ asked him
three times lovest thou me lovest thou
me because he denied Christ three times
he had to reaffirm his love three times
three times
okay that's deep uh so what would you
say is the the connection uh between
repentance and
forgiveness repentance and forgiveness
they're connected God forgives that of
which we we repent if I been a murderer
and I come to God forgive me he forgives
he expects me to turn away from that so
forgiveness leads to repentance if I'm
truly sorry and I confess and God
forgives me the last thing I want to do
is that thing of which I just confessed
uh to God and so repentance forgiveness
and repentance they're closely connected
one follows the other forgive me God
forgives you the Forgiveness of God
brings with it a change in mental
attitude you see and that new mind now
abhors what I used to do so when someone
is truly sorry it will lead to
repentance which is turning away from
what I used to do genuine for uh
sorrowful sin forgive me God forgives
you that forgiveness has power to turn
away from the thing that you used to
do perfect perfect uh so you know one of
the following questions I have last
question is uh what are the steps you
would say to break uh the habitual sins
uh you know that individuals may
practice religiously iniquities yeah
what would you say is the the steps to
follow to do that well I'll give you one
step which is indispensable Psalm 119
verse 133 now you said you know almost
like an addiction I'm I'm always doing
this thing over and over Psalm
119 verse
133 then we'll go to Psalm 19 verse 13
but right now we're in 119 ver vers
133 let's see what that verse says it my
step M go ahead order my steps in thy
word and let not any iniquity have
dominion over me ah now what's Dominion
is he control rule but notice the
condition order my steps in thy word the
word is indispensable to conquering sin
order my steps let my life be lived
according to thus said the Lord order my
steps in thy word and let not any
iniquity have dominion over me now go to
Psalm 19 let's read verse 13 Psalm 1 19
verse
13 verses 13 it says with my lips have I
declared all the judgments of Psalm 19
19 yeah n uhhuh okay verse
okay Psalm 19 vers 13 it says keep back
thy servant also from presumptuous sins
let them not have dominion over have
dominion yes don't let these sins have
do now Psalm 19:13 says let them not
have dominion over me Psalm 119 verse
133 tells us how order my steps in your
word so that no sin will have dominion
now let's go to Psalm back to Psalm 119
and let's read verse 9 and verse 11 of
Psalm
119 verse 9 and verse 11
okay okay vers nine reads uh where with
all shall a young man cleanse his way M
by taking heed thereto according to Thy
word now verse 11 verse 11 says Thy word
have I hid in mine heart that I might
not sin against me exactly so we keep
bumping into the word the word the word
now listen to what Jesus tells the
disciples in John
15:3 John 15
[Music]
verse3 John 15 ver three reads now ye
are clean through the word which I have
spoken unto you now go to two chapters
beyond that John 17 mhm verses now let's
read from 14 to 17 listen to what G he
is praying to his father the disciples
are listening of course minus Judas
here's what Jesus said from verse 14- 17
John 17:14 starting it says I have given
them Thy word and the world have hated
them because they are not of the world
even as I am not of the world I pray not
that thou should us take them out of the
world but that thou should us keep them
from the evil
notice that Jesus tell the father keep
them from the evil but and soon he'll
tell the father how to do it verse 16
they are not of the world even as I am
not of the world now listen to 17
sanctify them through thy truth Thy word
is truth sanctification is the process
of removing impurities from the life
Jesus tells the father what the father
already knows sanctify them through thy
truth the word of God has the
sanctifying power now even more
astonishingly read verse 19 here's what
Jesus tells the father in verse 19 it
says and for their sakes I sanctify
myself yes the same way through the word
of the
father they also might Sanctified
through the truth yes remove the word of
God you cannot conquer sin now listen to
these words from Ellen White the
ministry of healing page 458 paragraph 2
the reason why so many Youth and and
even those of all the years are so
easily led into temptation and sin is
because they do not study the word of
God and meditate upon it as they should
the key to conquering sin is the word of
God but here's another step let's go to
the Book of Job chapter 1 Job 1 we read
from verse
6 Job chapter 1 reading from verse
6 Job chapter 1: 6 it says now there was
a day when the sons of God came to
present themselves before the Lord and
Satan came also among them keep going
and the Lord said unto Satan when comest
thou then Satan answered the Lord and
said from going to and fro in the earth
and from walking up and down in it now
here's what God tells Satan and how he
describes job verse next verse and the
Lord said unto Satan hast thou
considered my servant job that there is
none like him in the earth a perfect and
an upright man one that fear of God and
ESU is evil ESU is to avoid God said job
avoids many times we walk into quick
sand and we say God get me out one of
the keys to conquering sin is to avoid
circumstances that lead to the
commission of that sin and God describes
job as someone who avoids as I usually
say you say I'm a preacher and I want to
give Bible study to the lady it's 11:30
at night and I go to her house to give a
Bible study I am not avoiding sin I am
setting myself up for all kinds of
problems we must learn to avoid if
you're trying to conquer smoking avoid
your friends who smoke avoid the smoke
shop uh we must how can I help myself
you see I avoid many years ago I did a
series of meetings in a certain city and
a young lady came to me she she want to
be baptized she said look here's my
telephone number I have deleted the
numbers of all my friends who had a
spiritually negative effect upon me she
got rid of all of them because she
wanted to live a new life we must learn
to avoid avoidance of course by the help
of the holy spirit is essential to
conquering sin you cannot jump into the
mud and keep telling God cleanse me
cleanse me cleanse me we have to try to
avoid the mud and so God describes job
as one who avoids he avoids sin when you
avoid circumstances it makes it easy not
to commit that particular sin and so the
word of God and avoiding change your
friends change your circumstances change
your surroundings change your
recreational patterns change these
things so that you enable yourself along
with God's power to overcome a
particular sin that has Dominion in your
life and that that's true you know you
the book right after which is Psalms you
could see the the the difference between
job and David because I think in one of
the chapters job said that with a woman
he he didn't even look I forgot the
particular verse he would look away if
there was a young woman but you find
David you know he he he didn't resist or
abstain from you know looking at basba
you know so we have to be very mindful
uh because we are
weak yes
amazing all right so I'll pass it back
to you
Denisha amen thank you brother Jonathan
thank you eldis SK praise God we are
back online I was able to figure out why
we weren't going live so we are live oh
we are good yes praise the Lord praise
the Lord so we have our final
question when will repentance no longer
be possible in a new
world because there's no sin you only
repent of
sin by the way even before the new world
comes you don't repent because you have
a carnal nature the presence of the
carnal nature is not itself a sin are
you with me sin is choice we repent of
things we do or things we think all
things we say we choose to think say and
do in the new world there's no sin the
corrupt nature is now destroyed there
will be no need for repentance or
forgiveness or anything of the kind
there was there's no more curse
Revelation 22:3 iniquity shall not rise
the second time 2 Peter 3:13 in that
land all will be right ousness that's it
and so in the new world no repentance no
forgiveness no Calvary no Sabbath School
courtly nothing of the kind all those
things are done away with and we live
naturally a life that pleases god with
joy the law of God has written our
hearts and we obey the way the Angels
obey amen amen I forgot to tell brother
Jonathan was nice to see him I always
ask about him it's nice to see him you
well brother still looks as sharp as
ever God bless you my brother amen thank
all
right amen amen amen and you know just
wondering Elders you know considering
that often well we know that the door of
Mercy will not be open forever that's
right that's right how how do we well I
guess that's that's the gist in itself
you never know when our time is up no we
don't yes every moment we must be intent
about committing ourselves to God that's
why the Bible says today if you'll hear
his voice Harden not your heart we do
not know when our probation closes if I
die in a car accident now my probation
Clos that's why we must live for God day
by day Moment by moment we don't God
does not send and tell even the most
faithful child of his when that person
will go all we know is I'm Alive Now
what is my relationship with God now is
there something in my life I need to get
rid of now is there someone I need to
forgive now is there someone to whom I
need to apologize now
now is the time we have life now let's
do what needs to be done don't wait
because tomorrow may never
come amen amen a lot agree in agreement
is saying the worst thing one can think
is that they have enough time oh don't
think that at all
M People of all ages die they die at the
age of 1 2 3 4 five all the way down to
whatever 969 like methus people die at
all ages every day all around the globe
you don't have a lot of time you have
now you do not even have tonight you
have
now yes between now and the benediction
some many people will die all over the
world between now and when we say the
benediction thousands will die all over
the
world this is serious business being
lost or being
saved it's the blare of thing so true on
that
one inde
so we're going to transition El to
taking some of our open form questions
all right I know we spoke a little bit
about
forgiveness asking how can one know that
he is Forgiven because the Bible said so
see God doesn't function by how you feel
the Bible says in 1 John 1 well let me
pray again father as we continue speak
clearly through me and brother Jonathan
and sister Denisha in Jesus name I pray
amen the Bible says if we confess our
sins he is faithful and just to forgive
us our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness it has nothing to do
with how you feel when the Bible says
Thou shalt not kill how you feel does
not matter at all just don't kill don't
steal feelings are not required for
salvation we take God at his word
Genesis 1:3 and God said let there be
like there was light no feeling involved
if God has promised forgiveness take him
at his word and accept that forgiveness
don't wait to feel forgiven accept thus
sayith the Lord too many people kneel in
prayer or stand whatever they do say I'm
sorry forgive me they arise and they
still feel Unforgiven that's not God's
fault you're not following the formula
accept him at his word if he says you're
forgiven if you confess you're forgiven
accept it don't wait to feel by the way
if there's someone who's hurt you and
you need to forgive the person don't
wait to feel like forgiving forgive
doing right cannot be driven by feeling
is driven by biblical principle if you
have to conf forgive someone forgive the
person even if you're gritting your
teeth forgive the person don't wait
until you feel like forgiving forgive
you're commanded to forgive do
it too much uh too much of our
relationship with God is based on
feeling I don't feel this I don't feel
like going to church I don't feel like
reading no no no no no there's a
principle and principles are not
necessarily connected to feeling
feelings change with the weather
principles never change when it's
snowing and sleeing and you feel
depressed when the sun is out you feel
enlightened and and you feel all alive
principles are not affected by the
weather or circumstances Thou shalt not
kill is Thou shalt not kill whether
United States or North
Korea amen amen or anywhere else yes you
know this we keep seeing the prime of
God's word we can't live without it we
can't God's word receive forgiveness
without believing God that's right and
neither can we forgive without the word
of God yes yes yes
yes so I don't see any other questions
so far if there's anyone here on the
zoom uh you have a question on
repentance that you would like to ask
feel free to use the raise your hand
feature we will unmute you and you'll be
able to pose your question
and while that is taking place those of
you that have joined on YouTube
Welcome Vios has joined happy Sabbath
mama is on those of you that are on the
various platforms thank you for joining
so if anyone you have a question on
repentance what is it really like you
know feel free to unmute now and ask
your question or raise your hand rather
and ask your question why waiting in uh
when Jes when Philip not Philip Peter
completed his magnificent sermon on the
day of Pentecost in Acts chapter 2 in
verse 37 the people said what shall we
do and Peter said in verse 38 repent and
be baptized every one of you in the name
of Jesus Christ for the remission of
sins if you read Matthew 3 1-3 John the
Baptist came preaching repent if you
read Matthew 4 verse1 17 Jesus preached
repent and Mark 1:4 and 15 repent in
Mark 6 verse 7 and verse 12 and 13 he
sent the disciples out they went
everywhere and preached repent if you
look at uh the messages of the seven
churches repent repent repent is in five
of the seven and even the two that don't
have repent they have overcome and so
repentance is absolutely we must repent
turn away from what we're
doing without that you cannot be saved
you can be a church member you can be
the head Elder the conference president
but you cannot be saved if you do not
repent
turn away from that thing make a
decision and let the spirit Empower you
to carry out that decision turn away
from
it repent from all this coming to church
late repent from being lazy repent of a
lot of things turn away from
them we have another
question uh this is from sister Alana
she says how do you get rid of those who
you have to cut off to deter temptation
but you would like to prophesy
to the Bible says in Acts
247 and God added to the church daily
such as should be saved yes we want to
prophesy to people that's fine but Eli
said the Society of unbelievers will do
us no harm if we mingle with them for
the purpose of connecting them to God
and are strong enough spiritually to
withstand the influence so don't think
you have to connect to everyone to save
them it is God who saves you live the
life God has called you to live that
influence will lead someone into the
kingdom but if someone's Society
endangers your spirituality you must cut
it off and let God do what he has to do
to save that person God has other
choices beside you do not endanger your
salvation because you are so determined
to be a savior God is more willing to
save than you are and so make sure
you're not exposing yourself to a person
and environment that damages you
spiritually and don't think that without
you God can't save that person God can
save the person without you because he's
the one who does the saving but living
an upright life is the most effective
way to influence people for Christ but
do not subject yourself to a society a
person who is detrimental to your
spiritual growth if your right hand of
hand you cut it off and cast it from you
that's what the Bible says
cut it off cast it from you cutting off
a friendship is not a
sin when I say a friendship a harmless a
dangerous friendship that is not a
sin amen I think that's a word for many
of us
today cutting off a harmful friendship
is not is not a sin amen
amen all right well I have another
questions interacting questions
so we'll take it he says another thing
that someone told me is that being
tempted is not the sin but actually
giving into Sines is that true well of
course that's true Jesus was tempted but
he was sinless being tempted is not a
sin yielding is the sin but we must also
be careful not to place ourselves in
situations that lead to Temptation first
uh Thessalonians 5:22 abstain from all
appearance of evil do not Place yourself
in a situation that invites Temptation
don't do that and then say well
Temptation isn't sin never do that don't
play with the devil avoid situations
that make it easy for you to be tempted
but the Temptation itself is not a sin
yielding is not the temptation but avoid
situations that make the Temptation very
likely and very
possible do not endanger yourself
spiritually
amen amen amen you know we must not lead
ourselves into temptation that's right
that's right that's right that's
right a lot of us do that have mercy I
have mercy you know I think you know
just on that point El theke you know in
speaking about repentance exact we we
must be intentional about creating the
environment condusive to
repentance those practical steps that
you spoke about before because we can't
expect God change us if we're not doing
what we can do like God will not do for
us what we can can do
when in the work of Salvation or
Redemption God requires the cooperation
of man we must do our part and God is
his that is clear in a very the most
popular bible verse for God so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth in him when the
Israelites were bitten by the serpents
Numbers chapter 25 21 sorry Moses was
told make a serpent of brass put it on a
pole they had to look if they did not
look they would not be delivered from
the snake bite we have something to do
but it's God who says but we must do
something we must cooperate with God in
our Salvation the way we cooperate with
the dentist by opening our mouths but
opening the mouth doesn't fix the cavity
but you must cooperate we must cooperate
with
God Amen powerful God doesn't save you
in a coma you must be alert
amen amen amen all right I'm not seeing
any other questions all right I see
sister Kea vas said thank you for VAs
said thank you for that answer Pastor
SK has said happy Sabbath I think that
would probably be about it if no one
else don't have any
questions we will close out I want to
thank you once again Elder SK the time
out of your very busy schedule with us
this afternoon although you presented in
the morning and
you're right this actually right right
yes so thank you for your presence here
do your listeners know you're my
daughter did you tell them
you they need to know that yes so they
can treat you
nicely okay praise the Lord yes
all of you that have joined here on the
zoom there's about 15 of us here I think
I could call all of your names since we
have a little bit of time left okay
sister Alana sister uh
Blair Carol Blair sister Cleo who was
with us actually at
churcha I you know have the Liberty to
call her cila Retta brother hope all the
way from for the whole what country are
you joining from is it
Ghana you can put that in the chat we
also have have brother Israel also
joining from Ghana oh God bless Ghana
yes Auntie Lura all the way from
Maryland sister Marcy Hort from my home
Church East New York sister Mimi welcome
I think this may be the first time I'm
seeing you here on Zoom welcome sister
Mimi brother Raphael thank you for
joining my mom as always thank you for
being here and sister precious is
on I believe I mentioned sister K viegas
Miss Maria's on
crystal is on and Z is on on YouTube
sister Michelle Roseman is here on
Facebook thank you all for your presence
this
afternoon yes well with that being said
we do have a meditative song uh one of
my classmates she's in the year below me
uh Future Doctor
olua ad has sent a recording of all we
ask you know reflect in on the responses
that we receive today through God's
manservant God literally wants us to use
our mind use our hearts use everything
in our being to turn away from sin God
will do what we cannot do that's put in
our hearts the desire and the power to
repent we must use that power make it
real in our lives let the word live in
us and that's how we turn away from sin
it's a gradual process it doesn't always
happen you know like this
but it's taking that step to say yes
Lord I will submit to you and resist the
devil so we will have this meditative
song and I pray that you know as we
listen to the words of this song that we
would truly make up in our minds to
follow Christ and allow him to say Well
done to us once again thank you so much
Elder SK for being here give sister SK
our love give the family and Texas
our to be here we praise God for your
thank you thank you thank you all right
[Music]
here
are here are humble
[Music]
preious
car
Liv godare
[Music]
give us
strength
holy Lord trength
to we lost
[Music]
holy
word
[Music]
your life
is we have
often lost our
way
H is
give us
thees truth oh Lord TR
[Music]
heart
and everyone who is in the
[Music]
oh
take me home with you my
lord when my life
is take me home with peace my
Lord let me rest in
you when I fall
the fight and I've kept the face and my
race on Earth
is
all
I you
[Music]
Lord please let me hear you
am and amen we we want to have the
Assurance but when Jesus comes the
second time whether we are being
resurrected or
translated that he is saying to us well
done you know the Holy Spirit impressed
me to do this Q&A on
repentance this fourth Sabbath of
2025 because many of us started the year
with New Year's resolutions things that
we want to do changes that we desired to
implement and maybe by
now those plans have fallen
through but today even today today now
we have the opportunity to turn away
turn away from the habits that have been
holding us Hostage to break the the bad
practices that we have implemented there
is power to be set free power to be
liberated powered to be freed from the
iniquities that we have been holding on
to and even if we don't feel it we must
faith it and know that if God's word
says we have freedom and victory that we
have it so may our prayer indeed be
order my steps in life my word and let
not any iniquity in fact we could
personalize it whether it be Idol
whether it be procrastination backbiting
lying kitous adultery profanity you name
it insert it there let not any iniquity
have dominion over me through Christ we
have the power to repent Come Just As
You
Are and stay and live be trans form I
thank all of you once again for joining
us this afternoon many thanks to God for
orchestrating this allowing us to work
out on technical difficulties we thank
God for Elder Randy SK and his
commitment not only to God's work but
even to this ministry thank you brother
Jonathan David Archie for taking time
out of your schedule as well after
speaking this sabbath to be here to ask
these questions on repentance and Dr ad
thank you for send sending we recording
and sending all we ask let's keep each
other prayed up and I want to invite all
of you to join us by God's grace
February 15 so this is not going to be
the fourth Sabbath this will be the
third Sabbath of February at 1:30 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time not 2 o'clock but
1:30 pm. for a Q&A with Professor Walter
fight on creation I think this will be a
very uh promises to be a very
enlightening discussion on creation
especially coming from Professor Walter
fight who formerly believed in evolution
and taught Evolution but after becoming
a sday Adventist was able to corroborate
the biblical account with historical
artifacts and just history in general so
invite a friend save the date we hope to
see you there and until then let us
remain faithful father we thank you for
your presence this afternoon and we
thank you dear Lord for abiding with us
and for letting us be conforted with the
word that in you we have the victory
over sin in you dear Lord we can repent
through your word through the avoidance
of sin through the infilling of your
spirit Lord we can overcome and repent
and you will say to us after that well
done we thank you for hearing and for
answering this prayer in Jesus's name
amen all right everyone thank you so
much for your
present we will now oh actually and
there was one other person that I should
have
greeted s welcome for the Marcus steel
from Trinidad Tobago God bless you
richly all right everyone take care and
God bless
thank you have a wonderful rest of your
day take care Alana my
attorney yes yes yes sister my doctor I
will see you
later yes take
care brother Eli I know you just joined
I'm so sorry we just finished but God
bless you the recording should be on
YouTube and for the beginning part that
was not recorded or rather not put on
the live stream I will be uploading that
to YouTube as a separate video